i have a busy
week
do yell on my first thursday nobu
vegas friday then i have a spray tin at
8 45. oh my god
yeah that's true thompson poolside
living her best life and for mom khloe
kardashian she knows just the right
throwback for this tick tock moment i
just want to live my life and be happy
and four-year-old true is taking note so
while chloe may have countless viral
moments from keeping up with the
kardashians
[Music]
[Applause]
the reality star opts for one with scott
disick
i have a busy
week
do you have thursday nobu
vegas friday then i have a spray tan at
8 45. oh my god
things are filling up quick
now let's cut back to true and yep
that's definitely the same vibe i have a
busy
week do y'all i'm gonna thursday no boo
vegas friday then i have a spray tan at
8 45. oh my god and it's not the first
time we've seen true on tick tock this
month
popping up in cute moments like this one
when chloe teased that she's got hard
eyes for a lucky boo you have a crush
yes can i see your crush
nothing pretty please face
yeah so coco's crush turned out to be
true but can we blame her exactly and
hey who says you can't have more than
one crush you have a crush
yes can i see your crush please
pretty butter face
of course this comes soon after a rep
for chloe confirmed to e.t
her and extras and thompson are
expecting their second child via
surrogate
it's a wish chloe's expressed for a
while
i don't know true's getting older and i
just feel like it's now time
to have another kid
yup
i like to hear
the only issue
well the timeline
seems coco and tristan likely decided to
go for baby number two before the nba
star was caught cheating
again i wanted to believe that tristan
could change i wanted to trust him yeah
earlier this year tristan admitted he
fathered a baby boy with fitness model
marlene nichols
months later chloe's focused on her
priorities and maintaining a positive
perspective
anything to do what's best for little
true
people do make mistakes and i don't you
know he's still a good person he's not a
good partner right he's always going to
be in my life because of true and he's a
great dad
and you know that's really all i need to
focus on is just his relationship with
true when it comes to chloe and
tristan's surrogate her rep tells e.t
quote chloe is incredibly grateful to
the extraordinary surrogate for such a
beautiful blessing
while the drama has died down we
shouldn't expect a rekindled romance
a source told e.t earlier this week
chloe and tristan's relationship is
strained but tolerable enough at this
point chloe and tristan communicate and
are on the same page in terms of doing
things for true and not together as a
couple
[Music]